il ya du monde cette année chez nous
c'est le leitmotiv des offices du
tourisme des commerçants des hôteliers
et même des particuliers bientôt ce sera
l'heure des bilans
ici le site le plus visité du
département des pyrénées-orientales voir
d'ailleurs de la région languedoc
roussillon
ce sont les caves de la société
d'apéritif qui fait le renom de la
petite ville de thuir
chaque jour ouvrable entre le 15 juillet
et le 15 août de cette année il y a eu
dix mille visiteurs 220000 dégustateurs
parents car ici le petit verre de fans
visite et gratuit comme d'ailleurs
l'entrée dans le saint des saints
la cave spécial abritant le plus grand
fut du monde 1 millions d'hectos soit à
peu près la récolte de trois mille
petits propriétaires
certes l'euro si on possède d'autres
hauts lieux de sa culture millénaire
mais incontestablement les caves du plus
vieil apéritif de france draine le plus
grand nombre d'admirateurs de cet autre
culture millénaire la vigne catalan